foreign who needs an uplift I do it's
time for the uplift to eight where we
share stories that will bring some joy
to your day and this morning we are
sharing the incredible story of a dress
that was about 80 years in the making a
young lady named Julia recently found
sketches of the dress that her
grandmother Drew at Fashion School way
back in the 1940s it looks pretty good
her grandmother never did anything with
these drawings on your screen right now
so Julia decided to surprise her and
actually make one of the drawings into a
dress take a look
oh my goodness
oh my goodness that is stunning
that is absolutely stunning thank you
that of course is Julia modeling the
dress she made and she says seeing her
grandmother's reaction was worth all the
work
my Grandma she's always been my idol
growing up so getting to bond with her
and connect with her through this
experience has been amazing she has
brought a smile to my face my entire
life growing up so it's a very beautiful
feeling to be able to reciprocate that
oh and Julia said she plans to continue
practicing her sewing and make more
dresses from her grandmother's sketches
which sounds like a wise idea they're
really pretty real
and they can share together and you can
modernize some of the looks but old
school is always old school why not
absolutely